oh my god it was so
embarrassing and so horrible so so so uh
so my sister cotty is uh i've said her
name now and you're gonna figure out
cody chrysler she worked at fox i think
fox now owned by disney right so her
very first day of working at fox this is
my and this is my sisters are always
funnier than i am my whole life are they
older or younger younger both younger
coyotes 10 years younger than me so
cotty gets her job she's working in like
promotions or something in fox but so
her very first day there
she gets a bunch of emails about
screeners for everyone listening
screeners in hollywood are like gold
everyone it's all the movies that i
haven't come out yet that are nominated
for oscars and if you're a part of the
academy or part of it you can get
screeners you can see all the greatest
movies that are out you can see them at
home on dvd so the very first day she
goes
um she gets all these things she goes to
her boss and she's like she's like i
don't i don't know what i don't know
what a screener is and he was like oh
they're the movies she's like what do i
do with these emails he goes okay listen
just write just write like a form letter
a reply and just reply to everyone that
just cut and paste it and reply to
everyone just tell them talk to tim jews
he works in the studio store and she was
like what's his name he's like tim jews
she goes how do i spell that and he's
like like the people jews the tim choose
she goes okay so she writes a form
letter and
cuts and pastes it spell checks it sends
it to everyone uh if you if you're
looking for screeners my name's claudia
i just started working here if you're
looking for screeners i'm not the person
that can help you tim jews in the studio
store can help you tim juice has all the
answers uh please i've seen him on this
thank you tim jews
next day she gets to work and she has
200 emails huh what the [ __ ] are you
serious seth mcfarlane writes back
there's only one she reads her email
spellcheck could change tim jews to
capital the jew and the studio store
the jew
can help you i can't please reach out to
the jew the jews attached up here
oh my god
she was she's not the kind of person
that finds stuff like that funny like
she was she's a very serious person yeah
and she was just appalled
i'm gonna get fired i'm gonna get fired
i look like a racist and i was like if i
go it's like she said
i forget what exactly said mcfarland but
seven mcfarland's reply was the funniest
oh and and she said it got sent all
around but yeah she doesn't look like a
racist she's not no she looks like an
anti-semite
[Music]
you